hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
perhaps the idea that Rene Descartes is
best known for is is what you see here I
think therefore I am
expressed in French Japan's donkey sweet
and expressed in his latin koji - ergo
sum' how does he get to that well he
goes through a process of methodological
doubt which is summarized in the
beginning of part four of his discourse
on method and whether we look at this
work or we look at the longer
meditations we see that there's a kind
of progression that the current is going
to follow and he thinks that it's very
important that we clear away our
previous sets of beliefs and that's what
methodological doubt is designed to do
he doesn't use the term methodological
here but that is something that it's
come to be called and what does he do he
says I'm going to reject everything that
is dubitable everything that I can
possibly doubt and he says I'm not going
to do this with with morals that we've
already talked about that in the
provisional morality but he says I I
wanted to concentrate on the pursuit of
truth so I decided to reject as
completely false everything in which I
could detect the least doubt so he's not
going to go by probability he's not
gonna say well generally for the most
part things have turned out this way so
I can rely upon it he's saying for once
in my life I am going to engage in this
rigorous scorched-earth policy of
getting rid of everything anything that
can't stand up to complete scrutiny
anything where there could be an
exception anything where I could
potentially be wrong as it turns out
that's going to cover quite a lot he
begins by talking about our senses sight
hearing taste these do sometimes deceive
a
whether it be insight you know he likes
the example of looking at a square tower
and it looking round in the distance or
you know they always love the example of
putting a stick in water and seeing it
appear to be bent even though it's not
really bent you might think of the
illusion that's taking place right now
as you are watching me in a previous
moment one that's now long past of me
talking to you about Rene Descartes
right that's involving sight and hearing
and the same thing happens with our
senses of taste or touch as a matter of
fact we live in a time in which because
of technology we have found more and
more ways to deceive ourselves about
this you know think about food that's
not actually wholesome that we can make
taste in certain ways right so what is
the upshot of this he says all right
anything that I've received through the
senses I'm going to assume that nothing
is the way that the senses represent
things to be now that's more than just
saying I'm going to assume things to be
the opposite so I'm going to assume this
thing that I'm tasting that to be salty
to be sweet instead he's saying I don't
even know if I'm tasting something I
don't know what taste is I'm not going
to make assumptions that any of that has
to do with anything real whatsoever I'm
going to suspend a scent or suspend
belief when it comes to everything that
comes through the senses that's going to
cover a lot as we're gonna see what else
can we go further with doubt Descartes
in the years where it becomes very very
radical because skeptics had already you
know suggested in many times the senses
are deceiving but maybe we could have
something just in our mind or in
communication or argumentation that
would get us beyond that so he says
there are some who make mistakes in
reasoning even about the simplest
elements of geometry geometry begins
from axioms and then it proceeds outward
through this essentially mathematical
reasoning or if you like logical
reasoning and everybody should be able
to grasp it and yet we see people making
not just dumb mistakes through
carelessness but we see people who
genuinely don't get it sometimes he also
talks about people committing logical
fallacies not people just trying to
deceive others you know by using logical
fallacies they fall into those fallacies
themselves making ad hominem attacks you
know the fallacies that have to do with
parts and wholes like composition and
division we could go on and on and on
right and he says I'm not claiming that
I'm perfect in this respect I have made
mistakes myself so what does that mean
then we have to reject all previous
reasoning and what we think to be proofs
including not just the things that have
to do with you know the world of sense
like physics or you know maybe even like
you know very practical applications in
terms of mechanics or cooking or
something like that we have to also
reject logic and geometry and
mathematics at least for the moment
he'll bring those back in very quickly
enough but can we call that into
question now you notice that's a much
deeper level of doubt than just saying
well sometimes the senses deceive us so
I don't know what I'm getting through
the senses he brings up a third thing
and this might seem redundant to some of
you but it actually does serve a very
important purpose in closing off
possibilities he points out that we can
have the same thoughts in our mind when
we're awake as when we are dreaming he
says they can come to us while asleep
without any of them being true
so he said I resolved to pretend
everything that it ever entered my mind
was no more true than the illusions of
my dreams you'd say well that's probably
you know covered under her senses
deceiving us or making mistakes and
reasoning right I mean those are things
that entered into our head but what if
we had something that entered into our
head and it didn't come through the
senses but it was you know things that
we we could say are sensual they look
like it what if what if somebody
implanted something in our mind whether
it be through technology or magic or you
know some sort of supernatural divine
illumination this would eliminate that
as well now we see that Descartes has
really stripped away so much that we
could rely upon one of the things that
he doesn't talk about here that we might
also want to bring into consideration is
anything that somebody else has told us
whether we learned it in a book or we
took a class or we talked about it with
them or it actually was something that
we worked out together in conversation
because our senses could be deceived
about what the person actually said or
if we were following out lines of
reasoning maybe they were actually on
track and we got it wrong somehow you
know how do we know that every time that
we add two and two it's not actually
five and we're just getting four and we
happen to be the only person who screwed
up about that but everybody treats us
differently we could come up with all
sorts of interesting ideas about that
Descartes doesn't do that here because
he's done that in other places but
notice that this hyperbolic or
methodological doubt it has rejected an
awful lot not only of our experiences
but even of our thoughts does that mean
that we can doubt everything here's
where we arrive at what Descartes is
going to refer to as his Archimedean
point the the beginning point that he
can use in philosophy
committees and said just give me a fixed
point and a lever long enough and I can
move the entire world Descartes is
saying that about the world of thought
so he says immediately afterwards I
noted that while I was trying to think
all of all things being false in this
way there was one thing I couldn't think
of his false I I exist why well there
has to be somebody something there
that's actually doing the doubting even
if I'm deceived Augustine had said this
Descartes says this as well even if I'm
deceived I still exist
in order to be deceived so he says it
was necessarily the case that I who is
thinking these thoughts had to be
something and observing this truth I am
thinking or I think therefore I exist in
French Japan dontcha Sui in Latin in the
meditations coach ito ergo sum this is
often called the Cartesian coach ito
that is something that methodological
doubt cannot erode or a face that is one
of the limits of methodological doubt
that is something that cannot be doubted
why not I mean you can say but I'm
doubting it right now oh are you you're
doubting it you exist don't you now
there there there Bentham of interesting
objections to this but all of them are
really subject to that sort of retort
who's doing the doubting what's doing
the doubting who's talking right in in
that conversation what does this give
Descartes he says I could pretend that I
had no body and that there was no world
those are things of the senses right so
we don't have to say that everything
comes back in because of coach Ito air
goes to him but we can say I had no body
maybe there's no world no place for me
to be in but I cannot pretend that I do
not exist why he says it's so secure so
certain it cannot be shaken by any of
the most extravagant suppositions of the
skeptics it is clear and distinct you
can say excused decart's criteria so he
says I concluded therefore that I was a
substance or a thing whose whole essence
or nature resides only in thinking and
which in order to exist has no native
place and is not dependent on any
material thing now that is more than
just the statement I think therefore I
exist but it's coming out of it and a
curt likewise thinks that ultimately my
being and your being a thinking
substance is not something that can be
genuinely doubted we can certainly say
the sentence I doubt that that's the
case or other people say different
things but if you follow de cartes line
of reasoning then it really is something
that can't be doubted there is an issue
that I'll bring up in conclusion should
we say that perhaps we could make
mistakes and reasoning about this
Descartes thinks that we don't Dakar
thinks that we cannot and therefore we
can't actually doubt that I think
therefore I exist nor can we doubt that
we are substances that are thinking and
whose essence and nature consists in
thinking so that shows us where the
limits do in fact lie
you